[Música]
la explosiva decisión del tribunal
constitucional de polonia que declara
inconstitucional parte del tratado de
acción a la unión europea vuelve a
colocar a ese país en un momento
delicado con bruselas que evalúa sus
opciones para responder a la agresiva
actitud de varsovia aún cuando es
improbable que los polacos sigan la vía
a británica y abandonen la unión europea
la sentencia que determinó también la
primicia del derecho polaco sobre el
comunitario suma más desencuentros que
marcan la relación entre bruselas y
varsovia desde hace varios años ayudados
por el gobierno ultraconservador de ley
y justicia ante esto ayer martes
varsovia mostró su disposición a aplicar
reformas en su sistema judicial y
aseguró que no tiene intención entonces
de abandonar el bloque comunitario por
ello ya quiero saludar a nuestra segunda
invitada del día ella es la doctora
beata wojna profesora de relaciones
internacionales del tecnológico de
monterrey ex embajadora de polonia en
mexico gracias por estar con nosotros
ponia en directo américa esta decisión
del tribunal constitucional polaco de
primar las leyes del país por encima de
las europeas abre entonces la crisis de
la puerta a un posible de un posible el
éxito ustedes si lo ve lo ve real lo ve
posible aunque ya a varsovia dijo que no
tenía intención de salir
buenos días era un gusto saludarte
efectivamente estamos en esta fase
difícil de las relaciones entre polonia
y las instituciones europeas
a la pregunta clara va a haber pool exit
yo respondo no y hay varias razones para
digamos para defender esa respuesta
negativa en primer lugar pues el
gobierno polaco lo ha mencionado
claramente no tiene interés en solicitar
la salida de polonia de la unión europea
si lo comparamos con la reina unidad la
diferencia es muy clara en segundo lugar
pues obviamente puede haber crisis entre
los dos países miembros y las
instituciones europeas y es el caso de
polonia y comisión europea pero eso no
significa que esos países salen
inmediatamente de la unión europea y el
tercer punto yo creo que es crucial y
clave en ese contexto
los polacos están felices en la unión
europea aunque tenemos el gobierno
conservador un gobierno que tiene una
política digamos de
negativa hacia la unión europea y de
cuestionamiento hacia las sesiones
europeas los polacos 70 por ciento están
bien en la unión europea y consideran
que en la unión europa les trae
beneficios entonces
sería pues totalmente equivocado salir
de la unión europea ahora vea está la
situación de polonia con los derechos
civiles hablamos del aborto de los
derechos de la comunidad lgtb es una de
las razones por lo que los polacos salen
a las calles a protestar y sienten
molestia no es que está pasando en
polonia en torno a estos derechos
civiles que exigen los polacos y además
cuál es la posición del gobierno podría
dar de alguna manera su brazo a torcer
mira hay dos o tres ámbitos en los
cuales efectivamente el gobierno
conservador de polonia pues ha tomado
decisiones que han sido cuestionadas
incluso en polonia y arise de hecho
hemos visto pues múltiples
manifestaciones de los polacos que están
a favor precisamente de los derechos
civiles sobre todo en dos ámbitos en
primer lugar la libre de la libertad de
expresión
e intentos de limitar digamos la
posibilidad de ser la prensa libre de la
televisión de libre pues han generado
mucha respuesta negativa y en segundo
lugar en la comunidad el gp en ese
contexto pues también ha habido
obviamente respuesta positiva de los
polacos aquí en las imágenes justamente
pueden ver las manifestaciones que han
tenido lugar en diferentes ciudades del
polonia por otra parte hay que reconocer
que la ciudad de sociedad con la que es
una sociedad en gran medida conservadora
es un país católico mayoritariamente
entonces se han generado yo diría esas
divisiones de una forma muy artificial
también a través o por precisamente la
política del gobierno que en su discurso
ha aludido mucho a los aspectos
relacionados con el discurso pues yo
diría casi ultra católico lo cual pues
obviamente no está bien en un país que
debería defender los derechos de todas
las comunidades lo más crítico lo más
difícil fue precisamente que seis
municipios de polonia han declarado se
han declarado como zonas libres del gp
lo cual otra vez ha generado pues
respuesta negativa y cuestionamientos de
la comisión europea justo este proceso
lo estamos observando ha habido hace
poco digamos la la respuesta también del
gobierno polaco a los cuestionamientos
de la comisión europea en este ámbito
veremos hacia dónde va a ir el tema
porque el proceso en general
en eso en estos ámbitos pues es bastante
bastante lento y sigue pues sus tramo
institucional pero yo creo que en este
ámbito pues ha fallado polonia que tiene
que el gobierno polaco que tiene que
reconocer que hay ciertos derechos que
son derechos ya reconocidos yo diría los
países europeos e ir contracorriente en
este ámbito pues no tiene absolutamente
caso si siguen las cosas de esta manera
beata la unión europea puede sancionar a
polonia porque ya sabemos que en el
tratado no permite una expulsión del
estrado de un estado miembro pero a lo
mejor sin sancionarlo
si de hecho ya hay primeras acciones
precisamente en relación con la
comunidad lgtb
las las medidas que han tomado pues esos
municipios esos municipios no van a
recibir por ejemplo el dinero de la
unión europea' recordemos que polonia es
uno de los grandes beneficiarios de los
fondos estructurales y fondos de
cohesión de la unión europea por otra
parte la disputa sobre sobre el poder
judicial entre polonia y la comisión
europea- polonia y el tribunal superior
de la unión europea pues a lo que lleva
básicamente es a que la comisión europea
no libere los fondos no apruebe en
primer lugar el plan que propuso polonia
para digamos el gasto de los fondos para
los próximos siete años y si eso sigue
pues podrían no liberarse los fondos
para polonia es esa mano dura se puede
decir el dinero que básicamente puede
obligar a polonia a mover a cambiar un
poco su política en ese ámbito la
política que daña mucho la imagen de
polonia es una política basada en
ideología que es más importante digamos
la soberanía del estado
el derecho de la unión europea una
discusión que lleva años se puede decir
en el contexto de la unión europea pero
el gobierno polaco se puso en este
sentido pues muy ideológico y no
pragmático y es lo que básicamente pues
está está dañando esa relación dentro de
la unión europea desde hace cinco años
básicamente y es que vea está también
estamos hablando unos 36.000 millones de
euros de este fondo que la unión europea
tiene retenido para polonia que además
lo necesita en todo este contexto en
este contexto de una post pandemia del
cohete 19 está estamos hablando entonces
de las sanciones pero pues bruselas
puede demandar a polonia
legalmente digamos hablando en el ámbito
legal como puede presionar bruselas a
polonia cuando mira durante esos cinco
años en abierto cuatro procedimientos
contra polonia arise precisamente de la
reforma del sistema judicial que ha
hecho polonia ahora está también el
procedimiento relacionado con la
comunidad del gpp y un tema en
relaciones entre polonia y chequia y
república checa- sobre la mina de carbón
entonces si obviamente hay posibilidades
institucionales que tiene la comisión
europea y el tribunal de justicia de la
unión europea para demandar a polonia
esas demandas pues obviamente tienen
como objetivo que cambie la actitud del
país miembro polonia en este caso en
esos ámbitos mencionados y normalmente
si se llega pues se puede decir a las
soluciones viables a través de esas esas
decisiones sobre todo del tribunal
superior de la unión europea señora bien
no hemos visto casos hasta ahora de un
país que se obstine e podríamos decir de
tal manera para no acatar lo que decide
el tribunal superior de justicia
yo espero que digamos próximamente vamos
a ver una solución a este asunto que no
puede se puede decir to heart de forma
indefinida así es beata gracias por su
tiempo por esta conversación por
hacernos entender un poco entonces la
disputa que hay entre bruselas y polonia
y esperamos que pues se solucione lo
antes posible gracias por su tiempo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa
beata muchísimas gracias hasta luego